an equal gender employment commission
leslie i don't think this is a good idea
i think it's a fantastic idea
oh i didn't know where you were going
with that the lack of women in this
government
is criminal i'm going to ask each
department to send two people to a
meeting
today yeah and and and
i can ask shauna mulley tweet to write
an article about it for the pawnee
journal
she's my special friend that's what
you're calling her now
i don't know what to call her i don't
entirely understand the behavior of
young people
recently we engaged in something called
a group hang
it was like a date but there were seven
other people there it was very confusing
i'm not really sure what our label is
labels can be bad but
they can also be good warning toxic
bleach is a good label
shawna maui tweep has amazing dimples
so the commission oh yes right the
commission i'm gonna get that going
right now great
wow chris your gender equality
commission is a real
sausage fest oh my god you're kidding me
i just assumed that some of the
departments would send women
oh my god i am part of the problem
excuse me everyone did anyone notice
that there are no women on the gender
equality commission
there's a lady right next to you oh oh
wait no
it's just a very beautiful man yes okay
we are gonna need to rebalance this
commission
uh listen you did a great job setting it
up and getting the snacks ready
but we'll take it from here well
councilman milton i did put the snacks
together and they are delicious i must
say but that is not the point
round of applause for the girl she has
to leave to get more snacks no i don't
this is my commission
ouch why so ornery
it's not the seventh yet
i believe one problem with hiring women
is that they're frail and breakable is
it possible you're thinking about
light bulbs or your hip hmm if i were
300 years older councilman
incoherent ramblings aside i've done
some research
and the female employment rate in
government is abysmal
the number one offender sanitation all
right
no no no stop celebrating why are there
no female garbage collectors steve
i don't know we hire women for other
things you have one woman and she's a
secretary
she's the best secretary we got except
for dan
dan's awesome and garbage collectors
make good wages they have good benefits
i mean they are the smelly glue that
keeps this city together you need to
hire more women not that many women
apply
plus it's a very physically demanding
job your average woman can't handle it
oh no
you